Yeah, everybody, dude, this is so fake. This is so insanely fake.
Holy
Much is so lucky he has me blocked, man. What an actually disgusting
loser this guy is. Just anything. It's so transparently fueled
by his hatred for
>> Much losing. What is this? Much losing what? New Michigan
Democratic Senate candidate Abdul El-Sayed for years has publicly
said he's a physician, but there's overwhelming evidence that
he has no experience as a licensed medical doctor.
Is he but is he a licensed medical
Did he get his MD? Could he practice?
Like did he get his MD and then instead of going into practice,
he started doing like politics or some sort of activism where
he was acting with his medical knowledge as like a core competency
to that field? He got his MD and then went into epidemiology
then public health. So, literally his MD is his core competency,
that's his core qualification, but they're like, well, he calls
himself a physician.
Okay, but is he like trained as a
What the That's crazy, man.
More of these lying people. Now, Nick Fuentes would have an assumption
about this guy right off the bat. I, however, am better than
that, okay? I would never make assumptions about this guy in
that kind of way, but he does seem to be lying. He does remind
me of some other people who lie a lot. This is like a a very
Oh, here we go. Sorry, but this is BS. I interviewed Abdul El-Sayed
months ago, and when going over his background with me, he immediately
made it clear that he received an MD, but declined to practice,
instead pursuing a career in public health. There was no hiding
/ obfuscating on his part. Repeatedly branded himself a medical
doctor. HE IS A MEDICAL DOCTOR. THAT'S THE DEGREE. THAT'S THAT'S
the degree. What are we
It's such a stupid attack. They argue he called himself a physician.
He is a physician. Okay, quick question.
If somebody's having a heart attack on a plane and the stewardess
gets on the phone to the whole plane and goes, "IS THERE A DOCTOR
HERE? THIS MAN'S HAVING A HEART ATTACK." Is Abdul El Sayed just
going to sit back? Is he just going to you know what I'm not
a physician technically I couldn't I couldn't. I yeah I okay
somebody was like to be an MD you have to practice. No, you don't.
People say like the dumbest things and I I have like a no offense
to the person who said that. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
But like sometimes people will say like the dumbest things and
I'm like I just assume you know something.
City of New York College of Physicians and Surgeons attest by
this decree that
Abdul Rahm
Abdul Rah Rahman Abdul Rahman Muhammad El Sayed is a doctor of
medicine.
Come on, man. Come on, man.
It's Dr. to you. Let's go.
I'm sorry. Like I understand physicians sort of like blending
something.
And maybe you could argue that it's like a little bit misleading.
But it's not misleading in any sort of like disqualifying or
or strange way even.
Right? I really don't think so.
Hutch bit this hard. All right, that's where we started this
all was Hutch. In what universe is this not deceptive lol? He
does not have patients. He does not treat patients. He is not
a license He is not licensed to treat patients and it never has
been. In 2018 he dressed up in a white doctor coat in an ad for
his campaign for governor and also used a photo of himself in
the same garb last June for a fundraising pitch. I don't know
where like do do you you think because you wear a lab coat like
a white coat
that you're a like practicing physician? Cuz I'm pretty sure
with like a background you can do stuff like this, right? Can't
you? Like if we go to Anthony Fauci
Well, I just had a picture here and now it's not here, but this
may be him actually doing some uh some treating of patients.
But I'm trying to pull up this picture right here. Like there's
a Fauci there's a bunch of Fauci pictures with him wearing the
coat, right?
But I don't know that he was licensed at the time.
Right? You don't know that he's licensed at the time. Like I
understand that he's a public health person. If he was saying
he's a doctor or physician, I would believe that. Like you you
have the degree. Is Jill Biden is not a doctor because she's
not treating patients all over again? I've never even heard that
that whole line of attack, but it's goofy either way. Okay, hold
on. Back to this guy.
Let's see. He He also used a photo of himself in the same garb
last June for a fundraising pitch. El Said's publisher description
of his 2020 book is is titled Healing Politics, said El Said,
was who could heal the sick.
Yeah. Okay. I'm sorry, but do we have we have no poetic license
in writing anymore? Where he went into medicine because he wanted
to help people and heal people and he realized that actually
he could do more work in this field by healing people through
public policy by by making people healthier by making a healing
his country political LIKE I ASSUME HE'S TRYING TO GET ELECTED.
I assume like this would be said in his book, right? 2024 he
said many of my doctors doctor friends call him a self-hating
doctor the way we that we tend to operate tends not to put our
patients first, okay? That maybe you could argue he's putting
himself in that group, but I assume he went to med school with
people graduated with them. I Bro, this is like the the lightest
misspeak. If he didn't have an MD, this would be disqualifying.
This would be crazy. But he's got an an MD and he's
he's done stuff where his MD is like his core legitimacy, right?
He's in public health as a medical doctor.
If it weren't that, I could maybe understand the attacks, right?
I could maybe understand them if it weren't that. But it's so
embarrassing. Definition of physician. Our American Medical Association
affirms that a physician is an individual who's received a doctor
of medicine or doctor of osteopathic medicine degree or an equivalent
degree following successful completion of the prescribed course
of study from a school of medicine or osteopathic medicine. Let's
look Let's look at this. So, to ensure patients know which doctor
is providing their care truth and advertising legislation requires
all health care professionals to clearly and accurately identify
themselves in all writings, advertisements, and other communications.
Requires all health care professionals to wear, during patient
encounters, a name tag that clearly identifies the type of license
they hold. Prohibits advertisements or websites advertising health
care services from including deceptive or misleading information.
So, I would say obviously not this. He's obviously not running
a foul of this.
health care professionals. I don't know if he counts as a health
care professional. Patients are confused about what qualifications
different health care professionals or uh the qualifications
of different health care professionals. Many non-physicians earn
advanced degrees, and many of those degree programs now convert
the title of doctor. As a result, patients often mistakenly believe
they are meeting with physicians, medical doctors, or doctors
of osteopathic medicine when they are not. It just says if you
have an MD, you could introduce yourself as a physician, right?
If you have an MD, you can introduce yourself as a physician.
This is meant to stop people with a doctor in English going,
"Yeah, I'm a doctor."
in some sort of health care environment,
That's all this is meant to disable or or get rid of, I can as
far as I can tell. Don't if you don't have the qualifications,
don't say it.
But this guy does have the qualifications.
He's not saying he's a doctor. He says he's a physician. The
definition of physician is medical doctor, which he is. More
info against Abdul, okay. Uh so, I would say that obviously you
want to go to the Michigan Board of Medicine to see how they
define it, to see if it's a problem, right?
AMA is fine with MD equals physician, but state law. El Sayed
has also touted being a physician in at least two instances when
he was in New York, even though New York state law prohibits
people from using the title physician if one is not licensed.
Okay, so you might have it up in New York.
What this tells me, right? When I look at this, what this tells
me, and we'll we'll actually look it up now cuz I'm annoyed,
okay? I'm annoyed now. They have annoyed me.
So, we'll look it up, but why wouldn't they be talking about
Michigan's rules if he was violate if he wasn't violating the
law or sorry, why would they be talking about New York's rules
if he was violating the law in Michigan and they could just say
he was repeatedly violating the law in Michigan, right? So, this
is the law.
We have Do I Do I have to read this whole law? Oh, granting licenses.
This is granting license to certain license or authorization
required. License or otherwise authorized by the article, an
individual shall not engage in teaching
advert or shall not impose requirements on graduates of medical
schools located outside the US or Canada that exceed the requirements
imposed on graduates of medical schools located in the United
States or Canada.
Notwithstanding section 616145
or rules promulgated under that section, the board may grant
This is about being
So, I understand that he might have violated this in um in New
York, right? But, the thing is he's got He has got
He taught in NY at Columbia. So, based on that he He had to have
been licensed there at some point. Oh, maybe he was.
But, in any case
even if I think worst-case scenario is he presented himself as
a physician in New York when he wasn't a licensed physician at
that point in time, right?
Let's say it's the worst-case scenario. I don't care so long
as the AMA says physician equals medical doctor.
He's like not operating He's not giving people patient care.
That's not what he's trying to do. Right? And he has the background.
He has the the actual education. This is an embarrassing attack.
Now, he might have been over the line in New York in New York.
He could have been.
No, he has a medical doctorate, Rhinox. The Nobody's disagreeing
that he has a medical doctorate. What they're saying is he wasn't
licensed with the Board of Medicine in New York to practice at
a time where he called himself a physician. And technically to
call yourself a physician in New York, you have to be licensed
in New York, right? So, two times, apparently, that's what the
political article says. Two times he declared himself a physician
in New York, but that was technically against disclosure law.
That's possible. If that's all it is and that's the only violation,
I'm not
Right? So, let's give this a quick read, the the political article,
and then we've got what this from Barbarism Crit. I'm a little
I'm always a little wary of the the openly partisan accounts.
Like this Barbarism Crit account is funny sometimes, but I know
they're overtly partisan, so it's a little concerning
Oh, I see. No. Seems organic. Oh my god. Guys, I'm reading that
like Abdul El-Sayed's a total phony? He's like a big fat phony.
He's like a big fat phony, guys.
Is he licensed in another state? I don't know if he's licensed.
Probably he might not be. He's in public health. He got a medical
doctorate.
I don't care. The AMA, the federal the federal board
for medicine, okay? The American Medical Association, the the
one that everybody turns to for like all of the the federal ruling
not rulings, but um cuz I don't know what official authority
they have. They're obviously like the major national board for
medical doctors though in the US. And they say you you can say
you're a physician if you have an MD.
So long as that's the case, I'm not really that concerned about
any of this. He's running for a federal seat. He's fine to me.
Now, I would say it's it looks a little bad for him in terms
of research, I guess, if he was introducing himself as a physician
while in Michigan being required to say that. That's a little
that's a little dicey.
Why is Hutch after this guy? Because Hutch wants El-Sayed to
lose at any
At any cost, it doesn't matter, honesty, nothing. Nothing matters
to Hutch except El-Sayed losing. Anything he can do to get back
at at El-Sayed, he will do it. Hutch had a rough one after the
AAS poll today. Yeah, that's what this is in reaction to, right?
Like I'll pull the tweet again, but that's clearly what it's
in reaction to. This poll came out today.
And I don't believe this is By the way, like Drop Site has their
own polling thing that polls in Michigan. I don't think this
is from that polling agency.
This is Abdul El-Sayed has gone up 11 points from the previous
poll. Like he's clearly surging in the polls right now and they're
all concerned about it. Yeah, that's what I That's basically
what I figured, yeah.
Are these BS debates over semantics? Yeah, I'm I'm just literally
saying that I don't think there's any
I don't think there's any issue to me
unless he didn't have If he was misrepresenting that he was a
that he had this medical doctorate this doctor of medicine, that
would be concerning to me. I would say that's disqualifying,
totally disqualifying, right? But
it's not totally disqualifying to me. So, long as he has the
the degree and he goes into public health and then all this he's
saying is like it's dude, it's poetic license, man, in a book.
But I do need to read the political article, too, so give me
a second.
All right. Michigan Senate hopeful Abdul El-Sayed calls himself
a physician but has little history treating patients. It's a
weird thing to hang your hat on in terms of biographical detail
if you never actually practice medicine, one Dem operative said.
So, I would agree that it's a weird thing to hang your hat on,
right?
But I'm positive, dude, wouldn't people who are lawyers who got
a JD, would they not make references to respect for the law,
loving the law? The fact that you went and committed to one of
the hardest degree programs that exists means
Like obviously it means something. It means something about who
you are as a
Right? When you talk about your respect for the law, that hits
harder when you have a JD. When you talk about how you want to
heal your country, heal your heal people in your country, you
want to heal the people around you, that hits harder, that means
something when you've gone to school, you've buckled down, and
you got an MD. I don't think
it's so ticky-tacky to pretend that this guy couldn't go spend
6 months and be practicing medicine, right? Would it even be
6 months for him to get
He did work as a doctor of epidemiology. It's not like he got
his MD and then became a plumber. Yeah, he's obviously gone and
used this as his core his core qualifier to be in public health
has been the fact that he has an MD. I'm going to play some music
while I read this interview. Or sorry, read this article. Michigan
Democratic Senate candidate Abdul El-Sayed for years has publicly
said he's a physician, but there's overwhelming evidence that
he's had no experience as a licensed medical doctor. This April
he gave an interview to a local TV journalist where he talked
up his credentials as a physician multiple times. In March
So Dr. Abdul made the formal announcement that you want to be
the Democratic candidate running in the primary for US Senate.
Why do you want to go to Washington right now? Dude, I so hit
the Uh everybody who's reposting who's reposting this who's like
going in on it is giving themselves is a giving themselves away
is a totally soulless,
devoid of any emotion or empathy husk of a human being, man.
It's I I listen I read the article. I pointed exactly what the
rhetoric would be. It's so obvious, man. >> kind of politics
that builds. That's what I got into public service for. I mean,
Demond, you know this. I trained as a physician and nobody I
I didn't grow up wanting to to dreaming to be a politician. I
grew up dreaming to be a surgeon. Then I realized that it was
our politics that was making people sick in the first place and
that's led me to a career in public service. Oh, it's so easy,
man.
It's so easy. The whole like healing our country. It's just so
obvious.
Oh, he's really playing up his qualifications. When he says he
cares about people, he was only willing to go to the like the
hardest program in his school for like 4 years? He got like a
He got like a bachelor's and then he went to like the hardest
program in his school for 4 years? What is he cuz I'm kind of
a loser?
What a performance. He's totally fake. Yeah, huh? Yeah, huh?
Yeah, huh?
And by the way, this guy I think this guy's good enough at speaking.
I think he's good enough at at talking to people that anyone
who tries to hit him with this is going to get thoroughly
It's so obvious, man. If you don't center the public if you don't
think the questions that you ask as a doctor, which is what's
wrong and how can I >> Mhm. When you're thinking about
the work you want to do, then you're getting it wrong. And unfortunately,
it's so clear. Dude, I I love He's really misrepresenting himself
when he says, like when you think like a doctor. He's misrepresenting
himself that he he thought about like wanting to treat
That's that's totally leading me to believe that he is a licensed
medical professional right now.
Uh-huh. that in DC, they're getting it wrong. Dr. Boo, you're
uniquely situated in that you are a physician who also knows
how to navigate the public spaces.
and political spaces.
Let me ask you this. You know, quite controversially right now
are some of the direct
Okay, you are a physician. He nodded. >> This coming from
uh Robert F. Kennedy Jr. Yeah. Let me ask you this. Is there
anything that gives you pause when you hear him talking about
public health um priorities? There's a lot of things. I mean,
we've got a a massive Um
Wait, so E sports Batman, go read the Michigan stuff and then
explain to me, like send me a little blurb on why you think he
violated Michigan law. If they're going to give you their stake
in democracy, and I want them to know I really care about them.
I I don't I don't have to do this, right? I I I trained to be
a doctor. The only reason I'm doing it is because it seems to
me the logical extension of what the oath I took when I when
I became a physician. Um and I'm trying my best to try and serve
that out. You not take the Hippocratic oath upon like getting
your MD? Do you take the Hippocratic oath when you get licensed?
I feel like you might have to take it both times, but
I do think he's talking about become when I became a physician,
I took an oath, right?
The oath I took when I became a physician. Is that what what
you do when you get licensed or is that what you do when you
get the doctorate?
how and where I see the problem coming from. All right, Dr. Boo,
you're going to be pretty busy on the campaign trail. You take
it when you get your MD? So, that's not even a little bit confusing
and this is totally made up, totally blown out of proportion
by complete
with empty heads. Well, technically, the New York thing might
be real cuz I it looks like you're not allowed to call yourself
this, but it's pretty obvious what he means here. He's not misrepresenting
himself. One of the ads he did with the doctor code thing. Well,
I don't want to sue him, but there is one thing here that would
be slightly concerning to me if he did. But we'll see. We'll
see if he did it, okay?
Let me see here. Hi, my name is Dr. Abdul El-Sayed. I want to
I want to talk to you about why I got into politics and why I'm
here to stay.
Now, I would say this picture in and of
is a gray area of misleading. Now, when is this picture taken
though? Is this a real candid picture from his past?
Cuz it Was he just dressed like this cuz he was in it doing his
like residency or he was doing some Is that was a part of his
qualifications? Like, if he was here if he was actually here
as a real person, he does look younger in the picture. If he's
actually in a hospital doing something in that hospital as somebody
with an MD, then it's not a misrepresentation to use an old picture.
He had 2,000 clinical hours. Yeah, everybody Dude, this is so
fake. This is so insanely fake. Holy
Much is so lucky he has me blocked, man. What an actually disgusting
loser this guy is.
Just anything. It's so transparently fueled by his hatred for
Hasan. What an embarrassing loser, man. It's about gatekeeping
the term to prevent pseudo-scientific sectors from the from diluting
the term. It's about the term in academia.
It's about the term in academia.
This guy's just wrong.
When the public hears someone who calls themselves a physician,
hears someone use language like our patients, and sees them dressed
up like a medical doctor for campaign purposes, this is obviously
deceptive. He is a physician.
He is a physician. He is a physician. He is a physician. It's
just transparently
It's transparently
about Hasan and hating lefties.
It's so sad, man. Everything these guys accuse me of is stuff
they're doing, I
EB got us?
Kind of. I mean, I would just say the fact that he's got 2,000
clinic hours to me just blows this all out of the water, right?
Like it Like right there, he's treated patients. He has gone
to a hospital and treated patients before. So, Hutch went from
COD streamer to professional journalist, jurist doctorate, and
now medical doctorate. Yes. Yes.
Yeah, Hutch Hutch just knows all these things. He actually misspoke.
I'm sure he did.
I'm sure he did. He's just dumb. He's like just transparently
dumb.
He is
He's like the He is unironically, and I hate to use this label
cuz I do overuse it a little bit, but I shouldn't cuz it is a
special unique kind of but he is like the Willie Mac of liberal
Like he just listens to the people around him, and if he can't
copy what they're saying, he will have to be incredibly like
deceptive and duplicitos in terms of navigating a conversation.
It's just very sad. Nick Shirley? Oh, the Nick Shirley of liberal
politics also is pretty good, though.
Oh, that might be He's a better speaker than Nick Shirley, though.
Nick Shirley's like unique in that he basically like consumes
industrial grade paste all the time.
It's like the Willie Mac IQ thing, and they can talk a little
bit. I would never say Hutch is like a completely I don't like
it listening to him, but I would never say he's like Nick Shirley
levels of speech. Dude, Nick Shirley like actually sounds special
needs. You hear Nick Shirley talk without a script, and it's
sad. It's like actually very sad to listen to Nick Shirley talk
without a script, man. It's bad. It's bad. Michigan law, except
as otherwise proved provided in this subsection, the following
words, titles, or letters or letters or a combination thereof,
with or without qualifying words or phrases, are restricted to
use in only those individuals authorized under this part to use
the terms in a way prescribed in this part. Doctor of Medicine,
MD, Physician's Assistant, MPA. Notwithstanding section 16261,
an individual who has specially trained at an institution of
higher education in this state to assist a physician in the field
of orthopedics and so it's got some other thing. Historically,
title certain titles are protected under state law. They always
have been. Saying you're a JD also this is not a part of it.
This is the person's opinion. Saying you're a JD for example
is fine. It's acknowledging a degree. But Esquire or
Oh, I think that's Esquire. Is a protected title must 100% accompany
license licensure. If I were to move to another state Yeah, well
I understand this works for lawyers. I do get that. I don't know
if physician here I don't know if you've actually shown me anything
that shows that physician can't be used. I don't know if there's
anything here that says to me that physician can't be used unless
I'm missing something.
I don't see this is saying that he can't use physician. So I
don't see I don't even see where the list of protected titles
are cuz this is not like obviously doctor medicine MD. Those
are like prescribed in this part. Like obviously he can use those
titles.
So this is like isn't even the relevant law or something. There's
something missing. I'm missing something. I don't know what I'm
missing but I'm missing
All right. I'm going to keep reading this. So I've seen how he's
talked in here. Is there one more use of physician? No. No. Nope.
Okay.
The most important thing to me right now, look, I I I'm a doctor.
I got into politics because I thought it was insane that in the
richest most powerful country in the world people don't have
health care. But also there there is no health without wealth
and right now folks are watching their paychecks get drained
for a bag of groceries that I just Yeah, I maybe this is you
know side stuff but I just can't see how you'd be upset about
this as a guy who's got a medical
It's really obvious to me
that this is not a problem. So this this interview not that much
not that big of a deal. In March he told a group of team certain
nurses that he had had enough. He'd been in enough codes to watch
who really does the work. Wait, but he has been in Unless he
just didn't treat patients during his clinic hours.
Right? It seems like he did treat patients though, and he has
actually like this to me as long as he's done
Been a doctor my whole career. Yeah, okay. Well, maybe depending
on how he said this, this could be a little weird. Hold on.
Been a doctor my whole career.
We have to see the context this was said in cuz that sounds a
little off, right? At the moment when there's clearly a lot of
pain and trauma across our state. Abdul, why are you causing
trauma and
No, I just I was I've been uh I've been a doctor my whole career.
And all my work has been about trying to put glasses on kids
faces and take on big corporate polluters and take on the system
that is polluting our entire
I'm going to lose it. The person who wrote this article is a
total hack. This might be written by Dan for all I know. Oh,
it's Daniel Lipman who sky did the original tweet. Total hack.
What a hack, man.
I've been a doctor my whole career. Is that enough? What does
he say he's done with his career, you hack? This is shameful
behavior, man. This is totally shameful behavior. What are we
even doing here?
Are you serious? Cuz I listen, I read that as a direct quote
and I'm like, oh, that could be him like totally pretending that
he's been treating patients for his entire career, right?
But he's not doing that here. He's obviously transparently not
doing that here. He explains that he's been a part of the publicy
Sorry, the public policy publicy. The public policy facing side
of medicine for his career. Now, those are the things he cites.
That's insane.
That's insanely misleading.
God, I
I don't know, man. I don't know, man.
His LinkedIn profile currently says he's a physician and late
last month he called himself a physician and epidemiologist at
a Council of Baptist Pastors debate in Detroit.
I think he is like classically trained here, right? But according
to a of Michigan and New York State medical records, he's never
been granted a medical license in those states. El Sayed's hands-on
experience treating treating patients appears to be a short clinical
rotation called a sub-internship at a small hospital in Manhattan
for 4 weeks at the end of medical school. He told the podcast
in 2022 where he said, "The job was to be the like worst doctor
on the team and he was cos playing a doctor."
I think then to me the code thing, I've been enough codes.
Depending on what other roles he's had, he could mean that he's
like there as a supervisor in some way at some hospital. Like
especially if he was a teacher at Columbia Med, he could have
been there for actual codes. He could like it's maybe a little
misleading. This could be the worst thing he said, okay?
This could be the worst thing he said. But again, in terms of
all the other stuff here and what they're trying to create a
hubbub about, that is not even close to something I would consider
in terms of voting for him or not.
It's transparent to me that this is just being done under the
auspices of making him look bad to try to hurt him in the polls,
to try to hurt him with voters.
The perception in Michigan is that he is at least at one point
in his life a licensed physician, said Chris Doat, an unaligned
an unaligned Democratic strategist based in Michigan.
Yeah, I bet. I bet. I bet. I bet. I bet. I bet. I bet. I bet.
Dude, this is totally defensible, easily defensible. There's
no doubt that El Sayed has top-notch medical credentials. Yeah.
This guy is very lucky.
This this author these two authors very lucky, okay?
No no no no no no no no. TOS we're on Twitch we're on Twitch
we're on Twitch we're on Twitch we're on Twitch we're we respecting
the TOS. We're TOS respecters. We're total TOS respecters we're
on Twitch.
Oh, yeah. So I think he's fine here. I I do think he's fine here
cuz I think this is a matter of perception and he's like a public
health official. So, hold
Okay, hold on. I think he's fine here. Let's pull this up. So,
doctor of medicine restricted. So, I do think he's talked about
having a degree.
An individual who's not licensed or registered under the laws
of the state of Michigan to engage in particular health profession
shall not use an insignia, title, or letter or a word or letter
or phrase without with or without qualifying words to induce
the belief that one is one person is licensed or unregistered
in Michigan. An individual shall not engage in the practice of
medicine unless licensed other otherwise
Okay? The words, titles, or letter of combination thereof doctor
of medicine and MD is not there. Where is physician on this?
He's definitely called himself a doctor. An individual licensed
to engage in the practice of chiropractic
can do this. Person not licensed or registered under the occupations
article of the public health code shall not use an insignia,
title, or letter or word, letter, or phrase singly or in combination
with or without qualifier words, letters, or phrases under a
circumstance to induce the belief that the person is licensed
or registered in the practice of a profession regulated by the
occupations article. Example, a shoe a a shoe a shoe store named
The Shoe Doctor would be allowed while a shoe store named The
Foot Doctor would
So, it's going to be all contextual. Like, is he trying to make
people The thing about codes, that could if he was talking about
being a physician and talking about codes, getting codes all
the time, that's like getting somewhere close to where you could
do this. The problem is the broad body of these things seem to
pretty obviously talk about his stint in public health and not
really focus on his stint treating patients. They focus on his
desire to one day treat patients. Right? That he got his MD uh
on a path of like empathy and in caring about
But they don't talk about him healing people directly. They tend
to talk about his journey through politics.
And so, with the broad body of the work talking about him being
a political figure as a medical doctor, I don't see how you can
make this case very effectively. But maybe that's just me. I
don't think it's just me though. I think like I'm saying things
in a more intellectualized way. But this guy went to school,
he got the degree. Yeah, cool. All right. Yeah, he's a doctor.
Like the the average person
is not getting is not like concerned about this, right? You could
say I think this is meant to regulate actual bad actors. Uh it's
clear to me based on the how much of I've seen this guy or what
I've read about him that it is not it's not the case that he
is just a bad
I think regular people Yeah, exactly. They just go oh, he he
went to medical school. Oh, he's like been in hospitals. Oh,
he's like taught in a he's taught in this field. Well, somebody
said he taught at Columbia at some point. I don't know how much
there is there. And then he has been in he's been like a operating
as a medical doctor, somebody with that that training in the
public health policy space for years since.